the fiance of one of two catholic school
teachers allegedly fired for being gay
is disputing the school's version of
events the school claims both English
teacher Paul Danforth and soccer coach
Michele Bedi voluntarily resigned but no
reason was given both had recently
become engaged the same-sex partners and
they were seen packing up over the
weekend outside Kennedy Catholic High
School that's in Burien Washington our
elite national correspondent David Begg
know is there David good morning how are
students responding Tony good morning
they're responding loudly in fact it is
the response of the students that has
made this a very big local news story
here in the Pacific Northwest but it is
obviously of interest to people around
the country so we came here to get both
sides of the story the kids have been
off for the holiday weekend but they
returned back to class today and there
is both a sit-in and a walkout planned
to the school students from Kennedy
Catholic High School gathered Monday for
a different kind of school project they
were making protest signs I don't know
if student that isn't walking out last
week the school said that the two
teachers Paul Danforth and Michelle
Beattie whom they called highly capable
gifted and qualified voluntarily
resigned their positions many students
and parents feel that the two teachers
were forced out because they were gay
[Music]
in November Danforth
accepted a marriage proposal from Sean
Nyberg the educator had been teaching
English in the school for five years
following in the footsteps of his father
who taught there for almost four decades
bTW the school's soccer coach also
recently got engaged to her same-sex
partner why would they be forced to
resign just because of like who they
identify as in a statement to CBS News
danforth's fiance Shawn Nyberg says his
partner is no longer employed
specifically because he and I got
engaged this is not only personally
painful it also harms former students
who looked up to them there are those
who argue that this is an issue of
religious freedom and the rights of
Catholic institutions especially what we
believe is a constitutional right to to
hire the teachers and employees to go
teach their children the beliefs and
practices that are dear to their faith
so you see this as trying to shut down
Christianity yes the parents who we
spoke to say they've been reflecting on
the church's teaching that all are
welcome everybody is supportive of these
teachers and supportive of the kids and
that everybody wants to make a change
and that includes students like
seventeen-year-old Griffin Terry who was
a member of the LGBTQ community it just
doesn't make me feel like I can walk
back into that school and then receive
my diploma from them like it makes me
feel really dirty that I'm gonna do that
we did reach out to the Archdiocese of
Seattle but they said they would have no
comment because this is a personnel
issue you should know that many catholic
high schools around the country have in
their teachers contracts a morality
clause which the teachers must abide by
the teachings of the church I want you
to know that both of the teachers in
this case have hired an attorney Tony we
don't know if they plan to take any
legal action against the school morality
is definitely in the eye of the beholder
David thank you very much it's really
hard to see the kids struggle like that
yeah a lot of questions there and you
can understand that how that last kid
felt you know saying I feel dirty if I
walk back into the school I still keep
thinking it's 20 20